sleeping evil long-lost heroes and a
world without wizards the rings of power
is middle-earth like you've never seen
it before
amazon studio's highly anticipated
series the lord of the rings the rings
of power promises to be an exciting new
chapter of on-screen middle-earth
adventures the show has been in
development for years ever since the
studio bought the rights to portions of
the lord of the rings and the hobbit
back in late 2017.
since then untested yet inspired
showrunners jd payne and patrick mckay
promised to dive deep into middle-earth
lore by exploring a critical part in
tolkien's legendarium events surrounding
the forging of the rings of power
[Music]
the sweeping setting will go far beyond
the mere creation of overpowered jewelry
though promotional material has
consistently hinted at a vast saga that
stretches from the powerful island
nation of numenor in the west to the icy
waste of the forward wait in the north
to the toasty southlands and beyond the
ability to balance multiple story arcs
set across such a large area will be one
of the showrunner's biggest tasks
far-reaching geography isn't the only
challenge though time is another concern
tolkien's world is known for its
complexity and richness much of which
comes from its sprawling intricate
history which the author mapped out for
tens of thousands of years in the books
the events depicted in the show were
supposed to occur over a sweeping 3 500
year stretch of middle earth history in
comparison the bulk of the lord of the
rings story takes place within the short
and sweet time span of a single year
hobbit occurs in a similarly short time
frame so when exactly does this massive
rings of power timeline take place and
how will it fit into the lord of the
rings history that we all know and love
well we've known the chronological
setting of the rings of power for years
now back in early 2019 the show's
official twitter page announced that it
would be focusing on the second age of
middle-earth this was exciting and
nerve-wracking news for tolkien fandom
who had never before experienced an
on-screen adaptation of this early era
of tolkien's world in case you're
feeling a little lost here are some
basic facts the second age is nearly 3
500 years long unsurprisingly it comes
before the third age and after the
cataclysmic events of the first stage in
fact the events of the rings of power
will be playing out somewhere between 3
000 and 6 500 years before anything that
takes place in the lord of the rings
this means a lot for the way middle
earth will look in the show for instance
the resurgent sauron won't be around
just yet while certainly alive
spiritually gandalf and the other istari
won't quite be around in their incarnate
wizarding forms there isn't a balrog in
moria and mordor won't yet exist there
will be a few familiar faces though
characters such as galadriel and elrond
will play vital roles in the show and at
some point or another we'll get to
revisit regions such as rivendell and
kaza doom and then there's sauron
himself whose terrible influence on
middle earth will only grow as the
series draws on some aspects of the show
might be unfamiliar even to fans of the
books one of the biggest changes in this
sense has to do with the timeline in an
interview with vanity fair in february
2022 it was revealed that the story was
going to condense the entire timeline of
the second age into a single point in
time the reason for this staggering
change is to avoid a ton of cast
turnover with the show's mortal
characters while this makes sense from a
practical perspective it does present a
few issues tolkien strikes a remarkable
cadence in his storytelling in spite of
the fact that it takes place over
hundreds of years the immense span
allows him to set up high stakes that
will be hard to replicate in a single
story patrick mckay and jd payne seem to
think it's possible to pull this off
however and they even have the backing
of the tolkien estate for their plans
can they really manage it that's a
question that only time can answer
[Music]